if you could look into their hearts and
souls he would find that they want to be
like the Ministry of Education in France
hi I'm senior editor Catherine manga
award and today with reason TV we're
here speaking with Bill Evers who's a
research fellow at the Hoover
Institution thanks for coming to speak
with us today thank you so give us a
kind of state of play 21st century
federal education policy where are we
now well the Obama administration has a
vision of its own and it wants to have
the US Secretary of Education sort of be
a superintendent of schools for the
entire country it really i think if you
if you could look into their hearts and
souls you would find that they want to
be like the Ministry of Education in
France or something like that so you
recently spearheaded a move to oppose
national curriculum standards talk about
that a little bit and what you hope to
achieve the US Department of Education
gave rewards financial inducements to
get States to adopt national standards
standards a list of topics that the
children learn in each grade so they
essentially the Obama administration
have got behind the push to get the
states instead of as being a resource
for states to utilize it really became a
requirement to get a lot of federal
money so then immediately after doing
that they instituted national tests an
accompanying national tests they had
national curriculum so curriculum is the
textbooks other teaching materials and
the way of teaching things and really
when you have national tests for all
students perforce really of necessity
you have to get into curricular issues
because just a list of topics does not
give you enough information to write
tests and you have to decide what is
important you have to
and what kinds of things are going to be
taught about what's important and you
get into curriculum and interestingly
enough three federal statutes forbid the
US Department of Education from doing
this they say don't supervise don't
direct don't interfere with curriculum
and yet they're doing this and they're
saying you know their their blueprint
for revising the major federal aid to
education law the Elementary and
Secondary Education Act goes back to the
lyndon johnson war on poverty days
includes everybody that wants this money
has to be adopting the national
standards and yet sometimes it seems
like when the federal government dangles
a little bit of money in exchange for
revised and policies reformers like it
i'm thinking hear anything like race to
the top which encouraged States to lift
caps on the number of charters and
otherwise allow school choice so how do
you draw the line between interference
that winds and tweaking curriculum and
interference that winds up maximizing
choice for parents and teacher them Sims
I think curriculum is what is happening
in the classroom and that is what the
teachers are delivering that are those
are the lesson plans it is so much of a
federal overreach as compared to just
saying collect better data or something
like that it just seems a qualitative
difference what do you think about the
Obama administration's performance on
education so far well I think in terms
of being friendly toward charter schools
and in terms of wanting to see that
there is better collection of data I
think I would give them recently high
marks when it comes to parental choice
beyond charter schools such as tax
credits such as opportunity scholarships
so we don't use the word voucher anymore
huh I think Opportunity Scholarship
tells its own story and a lot of people
do you know
opportunity make sense scholarship make
sense I'm but yes it's a synonym for
about alright so they have restricted or
I mean essentially Speaker Boehner had
to force them to restore the District of
Columbia Opportunity Scholarship Program
which is called the opportunity
scholarship so and then they were
reluctant to do this and the Democrats
in Congress were reluctant to do this
even though you know these kids by
objective measures were doing a grade
better than similarly situated students
and it was immensely popular and so
forth so they've been pretty weak on
that and in terms of consolidating and
trying to have this sort of National
Ministry of Education they're running
amok I mean it's amazing how many
millions of dollars are going into this
federal curriculum and yet there are
some in the digital learning community
who have supported Common Core
particularly if it's voluntarily adopted
by the states because that might be
another route to innovation that more
states could adopt the same digital
curriculum that's right they're
imagining the situation will somehow be
better it will be more political in a
more challenging way right now we have
50 sets of states plus local districts
if you're not politically powerful at
the national level but have a good
product maybe it's going to get tried
somewhere and see if it's going to be
successful we have nonetheless a
national market in textbooks so it's not
like economies of scale are not found
now and yet also differentiation and a
place for some small publishers exists
and I don't I don't see as we get this
national education industrial complex
don't see it I think it's it's really
going to block innovation but you're
right there are some people who hope to
help get on the gravy train sets pink so
very quickly what is the one thing
the federal government could do that
would make education better in this
country or not do if you like yeah I
think it would be a lot smarter if they
went back to collecting information and
doing some other things that have huge
spillover effects of benefits but not
try to micromanage the k-12 classroom
thank you very much for reason TV I'm
Katherine manga award